that is started.
Um Cecilia, if you can share your uh
Yes, sir. That would be awesome. While
you're doing that, let me introduce.
Okay. All right. Welcome to the DDPS
seminar everyone. Before we introduce
our invited speaker, let's go over some
rules and logistics. First of all,
please mute yourself during the talk.
But if you have question you can unmute
and ask questions or use chat room to
post your questions so that we can
address them in Q&A Q&A session at the
end. Second, today's DDPS seminar is
open to external audience. Uh therefore
no classified discussion is allowed. So
please watch out. Uh finally the talk
today will be recorded and uploaded in
our YouTube channel. Okay, that's about
it. Now let me briefly introduce our
speaker today. It is an honor to host
Dr. Cecilia
Pagani who is an assistant professor in
the department of mathematics at the
University of Pisa Italy. After
obtaining her PhD at the seminar for
applied mathematics of ETH Jurich in
Switzerland, she held post-doal
positions at the Los Alamos National Lab
in US uh and at the EPFL Switzerland.
She joined the
TU Aden Hoben in 2000 2020 as assistant
professor in the center for analysis
scientific computing and applications
and moved to the University of Pisa in
2023. Her research focus on the u
development analysis and implementation
of numerical methods for differential
equations. In particular, she works on
numerical discretization and model order
reduction able to yield approximate
models possessing uh the same geometric
structures and physical properties of
the original models. She's also
interested in robust numerical methods
and efficient solvers for fluid and
kinetic plasma physics and for problems
arising in computational
electromagnetics electromagnetism.
Today's COA will talk about dynamical
approximation and sensor placement for
the state estimations of transport
problems. I'm sure we are going to hear
a wonderful talk and now let me uh
before that now let me ask a question to
Cecilia just to get to know her better
and make this seminar somewhat informal.
Uh my question today would be
[Music]
um why do you like math? Except the uh
the reason that
um you're genetic like you're born to be
that way. Other other reasons.
Okay. Well, let let me first thank you
for the for the very very kind
introduction and and for the invitation.
Uh so probably this is the hardest
question of of my talk or at least I
hope uh well uh well I'm I'm very much
fascinating by trying to
understand things in in in depth. So try
to somehow uh give a mathematical
description to things that I cannot
explain like that you observe or you see
happening in nature and yeah you want to
somehow try to see what's what's going
on. So that's uh I guess my my main
reason. Um yeah, I mean that answer like
fascinated in me and I totally agree
with you. Uh but some people especially
my kids they don't
also also my students I think also your
students. Okay well stage is yours.
Thank you very much. Thank you once
again for the invitation. Um so my my
talk today is uh um is about uh the
state estimation. So the solution of uh
uh inverse problems appearing in in
transport problems and uh the strategy
we would like to propose is based on a
sort of a dynamical approach where we uh
perform an adaptive approximation
uh of the problem and also of the uh of
the measurements. Uh so let me first
mention that this is uh my talk today is
based on a joint work with Olamoola uh
from TU and former PhD student with me
Federico Bismara. Uh so
um see if I can move my slides. Okay,
perfect. So the problem uh we're looking
at is the so-called filtering problem.
So we have assume we have a special
domain D and E space B with a certain
inner product uh just to fix the
notation and uh uh so the problem is
assume we want we consider a time
dependent parametric process. What we
would like to do is uh to recover uh at
every time uh an unknown state in this
space V. So the state associated to an
unknown parameter that we call theta
dagger uh from uh m partial observations
uh given by this uh z i. Um and these
are um functions of the unknown state
through uh independent continuous linear
function as li that uh we are we are
assumed to to be known. And now you um
all of you know that uh this is an
impulse problems in the sense that um
typically uh partial observation these
observations are are not enough to
somehow been able to reconstruct
um a state um as soon as the dimension
of the uh of the approximations of the
space B is larger than than M. So the
only uh somehow possible way to um
reconstruct the state the state to at
least some guaranteed accuracy is to
impose some prior information on the on
the state. And uh in the uh in the case
that we consider here, we assume a sort
of deterministic setting where we
consider the state um to be a solution
of an evolution problem of this form
where uh this x uh is a general
differential operator that also we
assume that encodes uh boundary
conditions of the problem and uh it
depends on on this parameter theta. Now
um so the problem is now the the one of
uh trying to estimate the state u
associated with the
uh special parameter the uh theta
dagger. Now theta dagger is typically
unknown. So we cannot simply solve the
forward problem with the direct method.
uh but we want to somehow recover the
state associated to this unknown
parameter theta dagger by using the
observation from uh the present time and
the and the past times and also the fact
that uh we have a model behind. So uh
the fact that the state u belongs to um
the set uh calligraphic m that I will
use in the following um namely the set
of solution of the system under
variation of the parameter. So this is
seen as a subspace of say continuous
functions that are continuous in time
and uh belong to the inverse space. And
now uh the assumption that we consider
just to um uh for the ease of uh of this
um of this talk is that uh the response
of the sensor. So the measurements are
somehow um perfect. So they are not
subject to observation noise and also we
assume that um what we observe is a a
function of the uh of the model. So of
the evolution problem and there is no
modeling
error. So now um the the particular type
of phenomena that we are interested in
are transport uh transport problems. So
transport effects are somehow
challenging for uh for state estimation
for various reasons. Um let me just
mention a few and we will um see them in
more details in in a moment. So the
first um the first challenge is related
to the fact that um when looking at
transport phenomena we typically have uh
very localized solutions somehow waves
or wave fronts that are moving in time
and if we consider it if we consider uh
specially local measurements say for
example in this uh plot of say the
shinger um the solution of the shinger
equation assume that the crosses are uh
the sensors locations So if these
crosses are recording the information of
the state uh well you see immediately
that as soon as the support of the
solution is outside um so the sensors
are located outside of the support of
the of the solution then uh they do not
provide any information on the uh on the
state. So they they are simply
ineffective. Um secondly it is uh
um typically not easy to find uh low
dimensional approximation of the
solution set. So remember we want to
recover uh a particular element of this
set of uh uh trajectories associated to
our uh PD and for this we need to find
somehow an approximation of of this set.
Um typically finding a low dimensional
one is not that easy. We will see this
in a moment. And this is a problem
because there must be a relationship
between the number of the measurements
and the uh
approx dimension of the approximation
space to make the problem uh well posed.
And uh finally um transport effects are
typically characterized by certain
physical properties. For example,
conservation of mass or conservation of
energies of energy. And this is
typically hard to preserve when uh uh
when performing some um reconstruction
algorithm. So um the goal of of the work
I'm presenting today is somehow to try
to come up with a way to address uh this
uh these challenges. Uh so here's a a
brief outline. Um so the bas the
baseline of our method is the so-called
parameterized background data week uh or
PBDW uh method for for state estimation
uh that I will briefly recall and then I
will move to the uh core part of uh of
this work uh where um we propose a way
to dynamically move the sensors um so
that they provide um reasonable or
effective information of the dynamics at
all time times and secondly a way to
approximate the solution set uh that is
also adapting in in time. Uh and then we
will somehow focus on the case of a
Newtonian system by reformulating
transport problems in the in the
framework of of a Newtonian
mechanics. Okay. So um as a first thing
let me introduce the so-called
observation space. So um again we want
to approximate u an unknown function. So
the uh state u associated with an
unknown parameter theta dagger given
some uh observation m observation. So
um if we introduce the rits representers
associated to this uh um to the
functional uh functionals alli then we
can introduce the observation space WM
as the span of these uh risk
representers and typical examples of um
of measurements um are given in for
example in this in this table. So we can
have pointwise measurements. So in this
case uh our inverse space will be
typically uh reproducing kernel inverse
space and then the measurements are
really uh pointwise values of the state
at some sensor location that we call xi.
Um and uh uh other examples are uh if we
take for example local averages. Local
averages in L2 uh then uh we have
um the risk represent the associated
risk represents are uh basically the the
gausian centered in in the sensor
locations. Or if we consider for example
as a ilbert space h1 with u zero dish
boundary conditions then uh we can
compute the risk representers by solving
for example uh uh this uh this uh
problem. Um okay uh how then we can um
approximate or reconstruct the uh the
salt state? Well, the the task is to
build a so-cal uh recovery algorithm.
So, namely a function that assigns to
each uh time
um an approximation of the state the
unknown parameter theta dagger. So
basically uh to each time we assign a
function that uh when evaluated in the
vectors in the vector of the retro
presenters then gives us uh an element
in the ilbert space B and this element
is hopefully an approximation of the of
the state that uh that we are looking
for. Um so of course this is very
general. Um how should we should we
construct a recovery algorithm? Well uh
first of all the construction of a
should be based on uh on the available
information of course. So um we need to
take into account the fact that uh the
state u um belongs to the
uh set of trajectories. So the set of
solution of the of our revolution
problem and the variation of the
parameter and also we would like uh a so
the recovery algorithm to be such that
uh the reconstruction the so the
approximation uh that that it provides
respects some physical properties of the
of the
dynamics. Um so just to make um a small
remark we can also look at this problem
from a different perspective. So if we
look at at a stochastic setting then um
we for example can take as a prior
information on the state the um the fact
that this prior information can be
described by a probability distribution
on the inverse space B uh supported on
on M and this is typically induced by a
probability distribution on the on the
parameter space that uh that is assumed
to be to be known. So here we assume
sort of the deterministic more
deterministic
perspective. Uh okay. So how can we uh
gauge uh the quality of a recovering uh
algorithm that yet we do not know how to
construct. So the quality of recovery
algorithm is measured by the worst case
reconstruction error and this is defined
as the um supreum of all elements V in
the solution set of the uh distance
between uh V and the reconstruction of V
associated to the um measurements of the
risk risk presenters uh given by the
projection of V onto the observation
space. Okay. Um now the optimal
performance among all recovery
algorithms. Um so the optimal one is
given by um the function a star uh which
gives the infom possible recovery
algorithms
um of the uh worst uh case
reconstruction errors uh at all times.
Okay. So um there's actually um a very
neat mathematical description of of the
of an optimal map of an optimal recovery
algorithm uh which was derived in this
uh in this work and this is um so the
the optimal recovery algorithm evaluated
in a set of risk representers associated
to certain measurements is given by the
chip center of uh um of this set uh
which is nothing but the slice of the
solution set which agrees with the
observation. Um so if we look at uh uh
an example say the our solution set is
this uh
um space in in blue. uh then we can take
slices uh corresponding to different uh
set of measurements and then um the uh
optimal recovery algorithm associated to
a certain measurement is the center of
the chvy ch ball. So um the the ball
that fully contains the
um this slice. Um so the the practical
issue is that it is typically not easy
to compute this uh the chbbyev center
and also um uh most of the time uh the
solution set as a geometry that is
either not clear not known or it's
rather complicated. So um in practice an
optimal algorithm is not uh is most
cases not not feasible to to
compute. Um so to to sort of overcome
this uh uh this drawback um one
possibility is to restrict the search of
the uh recovery algorithms to linear
recovery maps. And this is the idea the
idea behind the so-called PBDW or
parameterized background data week uh
method. So in this case uh a is thought
um um among linear uh recovery maps and
uh the idea is is the following. So
assume we fix a certain time t. Um the
method sort of constructs an
approximation space VN uh which is a
linear subspace of the ER space V of
dimension N smaller or equal than the
number of of measurements N. And then
this algorithm assigns to each set of um
to each element of the observation
space. So to each set of measurements
um the element uh that minimizes the
distance um to the approximation space
bn and at the same time uh it agrees
with the data. So it agrees with uh uh
with omega.
Um so the this problem has uh can be
shown to uh have a unique minimizer uh
which is given by uh this element u star
associated to a certain given time t. Um
and this is given as the sum of uh of
three terms where v star of t is the
minimum is the uh sort of the element of
the approximation space vn uh whose
projection into the observation space
has minimal distance uh to the um to the
actual
measurements. Okay. So this um uh this
minimum
um as is unique and it exists provided
that uh n so the dimension of the
approximation space is smaller or equal
than m. Um so the um we have enough
information from the uh from the
observations and uh beta this beta is is
positive. Now this beta is an soup
constant associated with the observation
space and the uh approximation space and
it can be thought as the cosinus of the
angle between uh the observation space w
and the approximation space uh bn. Okay.
So
um basically the the ideal situation is
when um uh this angle um is zero and uh
it gets worse and worse as uh as the two
spaces become orthogonal. So there's a
second important quantity as you might
imagine in this uh in this whole
procedure the fact that uh basically the
solution of this minimization problem
minimizes the distance to vn. So, Vn
must be ideally a good approximation of
the of the solution set uh
n. Um
uh how are these uh quantity uh
quantities related to the to the quality
of the of the recovery algorithm? So, we
have seen that the quality of a recovery
algorithm is measured by the worst case
reconstruction error which is again
given here. And it also can be shown
that this error is bounded by the
product of the um what I call the
approximation error which is the
distance between the approximation space
and the actual solution set and the in
the inverse of of beta of the in
constant. Uh now these two quantities um
uh fully depend uh on the uh on the
approximation space VM and on the uh
observation space W. So an idea is uh to
try to come up with um recovery
algorithm that somehow uh is such that
uh this quantity this upper bound is uh
is minimized and uh this can be done by
controlling uh the choice of the
approximation space on the one end and
the observation space on the other. Why
I'm saying that? Well, um first if we um
could choose an approximation space,
then uh the optimal one would would be
such that the approximation error
epsilon n is small uh in a sense to be
fine or as small as possible for any uh
value of of n. And uh so how do we
construct then a vn with with such
properties? There are various uh various
approaches. One possibility um is to use
reduced basis methods or other type of
model order reduction techniques um
which somehow allow us to have um some
to achieve the best approximation error
um of for a given for a given size of
the approximation space based on some
information on the on the dynamics or on
the solution set. The problem is that um
so in some sense the good thing is that
the approximation error then it decays
as the commodoro bandwidth of the
solution set. Uh the bad thing is that
when dealing with the transport
dominated problems then this decay can
be very slow and this has the problem
that uh then the approximation can
become computationally demanding in the
sense that we might need uh a rather
large approximation space to approximate
uh uh the solution of our PD with
sufficient accuracy. And also on the
other hand uh remember that we need to
have a size of the approximation space
smaller or equal than the number of
measurements. So if we have a large
approximation space then we also need a
lot of measurements which is typically
not not ideal. So the strategy that we
pursue is um to
perform uh a dynamical approximation um
based on low rank approximation and
orthogonal schemes uh to update the
approximation space. So instead of
taking a global approximation space VN
uh we construct at each time a new
approximation space such that um at each
time at each fixed time t uh the
approximation error um decays to zero um
as n grows. Uh this however doesn't give
us any control in principle or in
general on the stability constant. So um
even if we guarantee a a small
approximation error then uh basically
anything can happen to the uh to the
stability constant. Um so how do we
control the stability constant? Then um
one possibility is to somehow um choose
a suitable observation space WM. Indeed,
if the uh measurements are um give
specially local information on the on
the solution as we have seen at the
beginning and we keep this basically
this measurement or this uh uh sensor
location fixing time then if we have a
traveling way sooner or later uh this
sensor will capture no information so
we'll be completely ineffective and this
translates into the fact that the
stability constant will uh will go to
zero as uh as t grows.
Um so the strategy here is to try to
move the sensor location to maximize the
stability constant or in other words
more more visually we try to move the
sensor in such a way that somehow they
follow the um the support of the of the
solution. Okay. So let's start from this
last uh objective. So how do we uh
perform uh dynamical sensor placement?
Um okay so the objective is to try to uh
update the observation space WM in such
a way that um
uh the stability constant um doesn't
goes to doesn't go to zero um as as t
grows. And uh uh the way we we
formulated this problem is to um think
of the observation space as a function
of this x uh which is the sensor
location. So we uh assume to have m
sensors located at the points x i and
now uh we want to change this x i over
time. So they are function of time in uh
and this will induce uh immediately an
update of the obser observation space.
So let's focus uh on the 1D um 1D case
just to make the presentation a bit
easier. So we search for uh uh the
sensors location optimal path um given
as a function of time uh so in in a
certain interval we assume a time step
for example from t to t plus delta t um
that satisfies uh this uh uh
optimization problem. So we are looking
at the trajectory um that um maximizes
the the integral uh in time of the
stability constant uh plus a a sort of a
stabilization term which somehow um
controls um the the velocities. So it
prevents unphysical large uh velocities
when when lambda is uh um is non zero.
And in this um uh in this problem so we
assume that uh the approximation space
bn is a function of time but it it is
known in some sense and then uh we think
of the observation space as a function
of the of the sensors uh location. So um
from this uh problem we can derive the
classical oiler L branch equations and
then we can solve this uh this evolution
problem um for the for the new
trajectory starting from a certain
initial position and from a certain uh
initial velocity of the uh of the
sensors. Um okay how how do we solve
this problem in practice then? Um it is
possible assuming that vn um at a
certain time t is toao sorry is fixed
and is spanned by uh the basis element v
i. Um so let's assume that is known we
will see in a moment how we derive it.
Now we can write the uh stability um
constant beta and m
um by um by involving two uh matrices
this M and G. These are ground matrices.
G is in particular the mass matrix
associated with the space BN and M is
the uh contains the inner product
between the projection onto the
observation space of the basis elements
of um of BN. Now um then the stability
constant uh beta and m uh can be shown
to be the the minimum value of the uh
matrix given by uh g minus one m and
this is a function of the of the sensor
location. So in particular uh as a
particular case we can also if we
consider if we have orthonormal sets of
bases for the observation space and the
approximation space then uh the problem
becomes the one of finding the minimum
value of uh um of the matrix G transpose
G
um okay so uh this is the way to uh
update the uh the sensors location.
Let's look now at uh how do we change
the approximation space VN. Um okay so
the uh the first thing is to somehow
rewrite the solution set not as a global
uh sort of a set of the global
trajectories. So the trajectory is
associated to uh to all parameters at
all times. But to somehow slice this uh
this solution set by looking at local in
time solutions. Um so we look at this uh
as a set of of solutions seen as a
function of the parameter and the space
but for a fixed time and then at every
time we approximate the state with um
linear combination where we have some
coefficients that depend on time and
parameter and then we have some basis
elements and these basis elements are
also time dependent. So um they somehow
are allowed to to evolve in time. Um so
in other words we can think about an
approximation of the solution set given
by this uh product of um of a space uh
bn of t um of dimension n spanned by a
certain basis and this basis can satisfy
certain constraints for example
orthogonality and and so on. we uh will
see in a moment um what is more
convenient for our uh setup. And then we
have a second space uh which is the set
of basically um uh vectors of
coefficients um that are for example in
L2 as a function of of the
parameter. All right. So now uh how do
we derive the uh an approximate? So we
need to sort of reconstruct the state.
So uh we do not just need the
approximation space VN but we also need
to be able to represent the solution of
our PD uh approximated in this space and
so the the idea is to uh rely on the
so-called deranker variational
principle. So starting from our original
model uh so you can think of a
trajectory in um of this model
associated to a certain parameter as
this curve for example. Now um if we
consider an approximation space as MN,
we can somehow attach the velocity field
of this flow to any element in this uh
in this subspace. And now if we use this
velocity field to describe the motion
that describe the trajectories then we
will inevitably go outside of our
approximation space. So we somehow fix
uh the dynamics uh by project by
projecting uh the velocity field uh of
the original flow into the tangent space
at at the approximation space. So uh
basically the der franker variational
principle determines the approximate
trajectory in this uh approximation
space mn uh whose velocity field uh
satisfy this uh minimization. So
um uh this orthogonality constraint in
the tangent space of the uh of the
approximation um set
mn. Um so let me
um let me give a a summary of of what we
have seen so far. So the algorithm goes
goes as follows.
Um we start from some initial
approximation space VN and observation
space WM and at every uh time interval
what we do is we update the sensor
locations starting from a certain uh u
from the configuration from the previous
time step um given the approximation
space VM. So this is assumed to be known
and fixed. We obtain new measurements.
We reconstruct the state using the PBDW
algorithm and then we update the
approximation space from TK to TK + one
and we go on. And now um what can we say
about the reconstructed solution, the
reconstructed flow? uh it is possible to
so to show that uh conservation
properties uh are satisfied up to uh an
approximation error which is bounded by
the reconstruction error of the state
and also uh some properties of the flow.
For example, if we want to impose say
simplecticity
um can be uh preserved exactly if we are
able to construct the approximation
space VN um in in a suitable way. Okay.
Because we then we can enforce that our
reconstructed flow uh stays on this
approximation space. I I have a
questions previous slide on the summary
of the algorithm. So f of n is the state
and wm is the observation. Yes. And you
assume that the all the initial states
are known and as well as the
observation.
Uh so I'm assuming that at the time zero
say uh you have some sensors that are
located and they they have measured uh
some information on the solution at time
zero uh on the initial condition. But
how about the VN? VN. So that the BN is
say um an approximation space at time
zero. So this can be constructed say
from um an initial condition on the uh
so you have an initial condition that
depends on parameters. You can for
example um discretize your parameter
space uh which you assume known like the
whole field is known initial condition.
Yes. At the initial time. Yes. Exactly.
Yeah. And then subsequent time steps
um you do not know those the whole field
but you only know the observations and
using by updating that basis you hope to
reconstruct the whole field every time
step. Yeah that's correct. By by
changing the um the sampling points
dynamically. Okay. Yes. So the the thing
is that at the initial time you might
not know the uh state associated to the
exact parameter theta dagger. This is
this we don't need to assume. We need to
assume that you know some um initial
state so the initial state associated to
certain parameters in your parameter
space. Got it. Okay. Okay. Okay. Thank
you.
Okay. So
um let me briefly go to the uh situation
that um uh we want to look at a bit more
in into details and the sense that um as
I said at the beginning we are
interested very much in transfer
problems and um these are conservative
processes and as such can be uh uh can
be seen or reccast as as anonian
systems. Um so basically this boils down
to have a uh an operator which
represents the velocity field of of the
of the evolution of the flow uh of this
form. Um where
um we we make a sort of an assumption
that uh we consider in in in this
setting aonian system in canonical form.
Uh so basically now the idea is to
consider as a ilbert space um the
product of uh two spaces v hat. So each
vhat is an iber space and um uh this uh
is endowed other than with an inner
product also with an operator uh this j
that um acts in this way. So uh is given
by the identity in the sort of off
diagonal blocks. So with respect to this
um vhat cross V hat and uh this poson
tensor identifies a simple form omega uh
which is given in this way with respect
to the inner product on on b and uh this
h quantity here so this is the fch
derivative of h uh theta is a a function
of uh uh it depends on the parameter and
for each pared parameter it's a conserve
the quantity. So now the idea would be
uh can we find an approximation space
and evolve it in time um uh that it's a
good approximation of the dynamics and
somehow preserve this uh uh this
structure and so the idea is very much
what we have seen before. We need to
make some uh very special choices um at
some point. So uh again what we do is uh
um we approximate uh the solution at
each time t um with a linear
combination. We need um an even number
of uh of unknown because of the tensor
structure of of our um ibra space and
then what we do is exactly as before. So
we consider an approximation space M2R
given by uh the product of V2R which is
the span of some basis elements and we
ask this basis elements to be uh simple
uh to be a simple basis and to satisfy
also orthogonality uh condition with
respect to the inner product on on B.
And secondly, we need to um uh ask that
the set of coefficients uh as a function
of the of the parameter um uh satisfy a
certain rank condition um u in
particular the rank of this uh uh of
this matrix uh needs to be uh full rank.
2R and this is necessary to sort of
endow um to guarantee the uniqueness of
the representation of each element in
M2R as the linear combination of certain
coefficients and certain uh basis
elements. Um okay so uh to derive the uh
evolution equation again we apply the
droational principle. So we somehow um
minimize approximated dynamics with the
velocity field uh that
um uh is orthogonal
um uh to two elements in the tangent
space and now this orthogonality is
taken with respect to the simplectic to
form or omega. So this is uh the new
condition. So without going into the
details of the of the derivation then
one uh can derive an evolution equation
uh for the set of basis elements and
also for the set of coefficients. So the
basis elements are needed uh to describe
the approximation space at each time uh
and the coefficients are needed also for
the reconstruction of the solution.
Okay. So in principle uh say for the
sensor um for the sensor placement we
only need uh the information on the
approximation space but then whenever we
need to reconstruct the solution we uh
of course we need also to have uh its
representation. So the the coefficient
CI C2R
um all right so let me uh go to um one
numerical simulation. Uh this is the uh
nonlinear shortinger equation a simple
test case in in 1D. uh our inverse space
is L2 on the domain D given here and um
we consider as two parameters one is in
the initial condition and and another
one is in the uh nonlinear part of the
uh of the dynamics and then as a
reference solution so to make a um
comparison we um run an high fidelity uh
simulation of the forward problem by
using a second order um discretization
in time and and space. Um and for the
approximate model
um we solve with a structure preserving
time integration scheme uh using a
subset of 100 training parameters and
the dimension of our approximation space
will be eight. And for the measurements
we consider six uh sensors located at
certain points uh in this uh in this
interval. and we assume that we can
somehow record uh the real and imaginary
part of our um uh of the of the
solution. So now here um you see um
uh four plots. So the first column
refers to the uh PBDW algorithm uh the
standard one so without uh dynamical
adaptation of the state and of the
sensors and the second column uh is in
instead refers to our algorithm. So in
the first plot on the on the left you
see um uh this is basically the uh the
black dash line is the um is the maximum
of the hump um that is traveling in the
um in time and uh so how it's moving in
the space time space-time domain and the
uh the color lines refer to the uh
position of the sensors over time. So
the sensors are located at certain
location at the beginning and they
remain so until the final time and then
you immediately see here how the
stability constant va behaves in time.
So um as long the as the sensors are
able to somehow capture some information
on the dynamics things are good somehow
they're rather mild but then as soon as
there is um no more information coming
from the measurements the problem starts
to become unstable and the beta starts
to become uh small. Um on the other hand
if we look at the second column then we
see that we can achieve
um a beta that uh doesn't decrease
considerably uh if we allow the sensors
to somehow follow the uh the dynamics of
the of the solution. Um so what about
the reconstruction error? So in these
two plots again you see first column the
traditional static PBDW approach second
column the uh dynamic one and you see
three lines um the top one which is a
red um represents the an upper bound of
the error. So it's given by the
um well the middle one is the
reconstruction error. So what we obtain
and then uh the upper one is the upper
bound and the the lower one is a lower
bound. Uh the lower bound is given by
the projection error. So the best we can
do in this approximation space VN and
the upper one is the projection error
multiplied by the inverse of the of the
stability constant. And then you see
that uh with the static approach then uh
the error can actually become uh uh
rather large. it's of the order of one.
While uh with the dynamic approach we
can achieve
um a reasonably small error of course
depends on the uh on the properties of
our approximation space also on its size
but the good thing is that it's it
remains close to the target. So the best
we can do with such an approximation
which is the uh yellow line. Okay.
Finally, if we look at some qualitative
um property of the reconstruction, then
you see um in the top row the real and
imaginary part of the uh reconstructed
state for a certain parameter that we
have uh um fixed and we have run the um
high fidelity forward problem is the
black line with um with circles. um the
red line which basically overlaps the
dash uh red line is our dynamic
approach. So basically there is no
qualitative difference between the two
uh the reconstructing solution and the
actual one the solution of the forward
problem. While um if we use a standard
uh static PBDW then we observe a somehow
qualitatively wrong uh reconstructed
state. And if we look at the yes um so
this particular numerical examples init
for the static one the sampling um
points was skewed to the um the left
hand side right from 10 to 15 if I
remember correctly from the previous
slide what where was the sampling point
um the obser
the okay this was the one where we
somehow make the comparison
1.04 to 1 point
what where was the the location of the
samples for the static
one is it uniformly is distributed or uh
yeah it's the same uh yeah 100 uh
parameters
I'm I'm talking about the observation ah
the observations see yes these are uh
the sensors location
and it's skewed um to bottom and that
corresponds to the the numerical results
you're showing. Yes. Yes. That's skewed
to the one side, right? Yeah. Yeah.
Okay. That that was what I was asking.
Okay. Okay. And and then that's why um
um Yeah. Can you go back to where you
were? Uh this one. Yeah. Yeah. Yeah.
That's why you know the glue in the
middle it was not doing well. Um
probably they they didn't have the
observation. Yes, exactly. Because this
is at at the final at the final time. So
yeah. Yeah. The information is really
not uh um the sensors are providing no
effective information on the dynamics.
Yeah. Which makes sense. Yeah. Totally
makes sense. Yeah.
All right. Don't sorry to interrupt. Uh
no not at all. Um so even if we look at
the Hamiltonian conservation so um if
you look at the first plot on the uh
left um well you see that um the blue
line so the one associated with the
classical static uh sensors location uh
gives becomes unstable. So the
Hamiltonian is uh is not conserved.
Um concerning the dynamic approach then
well from this plot you think it is
exactly conserved. So it is definitely
um gives better results but if we look
at the muttonian error so the plots on
the right then we observe that um uh the
error is so the Hamiltonian is not
conserved to machine precision uh but it
has an error and this error is
proportional to the reconstruction
error. So we can guarantee that this
error is bounded uh by the
reconstruction
error. Okay. So
um let me wrap up and uh uh so I I've
presented a possible way to um solve the
filtering problem with the PBDW uh
algorithm um with dynamical
approximation and sensor replacement.
Um the key the key points are uh
evolving uh approximation space and
these allow lowdimensional
um approximations. Uh also moving the
sensors is playing a crucial role to
guarantee good reconstruction and also a
stable one especially in transport
dominated problems or problems where we
have a um very localized solution. And
it is also possible to incorporate some
physical properties of the u of the
dynamics um if the this dynamical
approximate models and approximation
space are constructed with certain uh
built-in uh properties. Um so there are
many possible extensions. So we have
considered the problem of state
estimation. uh one could also think
about how to do the uh parameter
estimation in uh in this context. Um so
in the in this numerical test that I've
shown we have assumed that we know the
uh we can somehow measure um the real
and imaginary part of our solution. This
this might not be possible or also um
one might need to work with nonlinear
observations. And then what how do we
extend this uh uh this method to this
case? Um also we would like to have
somehow a sort of feedback um uh loop in
the sense that we would like to have the
evolution of the approximation space to
be informed um uh of the local
reconstruction say um uh in time in real
time. Um I'm sure there are many more uh
open questions. Uh uh with this I I uh
would like to conclude and thank you
very much for your attention.
Fantastic. Wonderful talk Sicilia. Thank
you so much. Um okay, let's have a Q&A
session. Car I see the Carlos hands up.
Do you want to Hello. Uh can you hear
me? Yes sir. Yeah. Um so I wanted to ask
kind of maybe a stupid question but uh
when it comes to let's say industrial
applications or practical applications
uh what kind of um framework would you
envision these working? Um do you see
any particular problems where this kind
of moving sensors could be applied and
what would the let's say control loop uh
look
like? Um so all right um well at the
moment this this old setup has been
tested for uh academic problems where we
also assume to be to have uh
measurements that are given by exact
evaluation of the uh of the solution of
our model. Um so the kind of setting
where where this kind of approach would
perform best is exactly when uh you have
um dynamics that uh sort of uh transport
effect. So solutions that are all
localized and they are moving in time
but also in situation where you can
somehow afford to move the sensors
because this might not be always the
case and this I do understand. Um so if
uh if one has the chance to move um the
sensors so to somehow take measurements
over time um at different locations uh
then uh this this would be good if the
solution is uh is very localized and
this provides um a sort of um algorithm
to sort of be able to trace where the
solution is moving in space.
Nice. Thank you very much. Thank you.
Very very well. Um very well done.
Um I have some questions if not if there
is no other questions. Um please hands
up or put your questions in the in the
chat room if you do. Um meanwhile I
would like to ask bunch of questions.
very exciting and very interesting
topic. It's in spirit pretty similar to
gapy pod gapy proposed de composition in
a sense that it's it uses some basis and
then uh it lets you reconstruct the
whole field using just sampled points
but the difference I clearly see that um
you do not have to well I mean it's a
dynamic it's adaptive you you you allow
your your sample points to be moved
around depending on where the fields are
moving
uh based on the reconstruction you have
done and also um you do not assume the
basis
um to be constructed you know knowing
the the snapshots from other parameter
space like everywhere in space and time
you only assumed maybe some initial
conditions you use the snapshots to
construct the basis so in that sense
it's more more general than gap I I I
see. Um so very fascinating. Um if if
you can comment on the difference
between your meth algorithm and gap that
would be awesome. Uh yeah. So in so in
this setting if we look at the uh
evolution of our approximation space
basically we
um this is not data driven in in a sense
uh in the sense that we do not need to
have um right information on the
dynamics or on the solution set except
as you said from some initial condition.
Yeah, at some parameter but then we
basically adapt on the fly based only on
the PD sort of on the information that
comes from the um from the dynamics. So
in some sense if you want to have a a
purely datadriven blackbox approach this
is not possible because you need somehow
to have an information on the
differential operator on the velocity
field of the flow. But this vice versa
doesn't need any prior information right
any well not prior in the you need it in
the sense of the inverse problems but
you don't need for the approximation any
information on the dynamics uh nor
locally uh not even globally as would
pod or gapy pod uh do
yeah well okay related to the uh carosis
questions in order to
apply this method to let's say some sort
of experiments. Um and the fields are
like very transport dominated orction
dominated. Um then but the experiment is
like is moving pretty fast. Uh in order
to incorporate that situations your
algorithm computational post has to be
pretty um pretty real time.
Right. Yes. And yeah, can you comment on
that? What is the computational cost
then? Can can it be applied to that real
time experiment? Um you know uh yeah
okay so um if you have a dynamics that
is moving uh fast then uh basically what
uh you have basically two options. Let's
say uh you can um have a rather large
approximation space and then somehow
afford a larger time steps ideally so
that uh with a larger approximation
space you can hopefully capture more
dynamics.
um uh or otherwise which is basically
the the idea behind the uh this
dynamical approach is that you would
update uh your space very frequently. Uh
but the fact that somehow your
approximation is based on um a slice of
the solution set at a given time. Um if
your solution is somehow as a
lowdimensional representation as a
function of parameter for fixed time
then you can have a cheap
representation. So um uh bn with n small
um that is however changing rather fast.
um then you could argue that uh uh then
this n um might not might be suitable at
the beginning of the simulation but then
you might need a larger approximation
space then yeah there are there are
algorithm
with that are rank adaptive in the sense
that you can also update the size of
your approximation space say enlarging
it or um shrinking it depending on on
the dynamics
Okay, thank you Sius. Um, Tony, I I see
your hands up. Uh, do you want to unmute
and ask? Sure. Thanks. Yeah, thanks
Cecilia for the wonderful talk. Uh, so
uh while the method clearly avoids the
uh full stage solves and leverage the
low approximation space, I still have a
question regarding the computational
efficiency. Maybe I missed something. So
given that this approach involves
recomputing the projections and the
sensor placement online, I'm wondering
if it does not have the usual
computational gain as in the classical
offline online splitting in the usual
reducal models. So I want to ask if you
have observed practical runtime benefits
in your experiments.
Um okay. So um uh two things maybe um
are so the first one is that um if you
have um a sort of a nice problem in the
sense of being reducible in the sense of
uh uh being in the situation where your
uh model order reduction um algorithm
ensures that the approximation uh the
approximation error uh decays as the
column of RO bandwidth of the solution
set and your solution set um as a
cologar bandwidth that decays
exponentially fast. For example, say you
are in a
um elliptic parabolic type of framework
then um you might have incredible speed
up with the classical offline online uh
approach and uh that's unbeatable. Uh
the thing is when you consider transport
dominated problems uh then this
commodoro bandwidth can decay uh
extremely slow and the thing is that you
um then you need an extremely large
approximation space. So then the gain
online is not that clear in the context
of reconstruction state reconstruction.
This is also a problem because then we
need really a lot of measurements if we
have a large approximation space and
this would be a an extremely um costly
uh type of uh algorithm. So an offline
online splitting uh would would not uh
uh pay off. instead of uh if you if you
do this sort of uh adaptivity
um then you can guarantee that uh uh
this adaptation has a cost. Uh this this
is for sure. So I agree with you. But
the fact that you can allow small
approximation space and small
observation spaces is what um is what
makes it um sort of um the performances
are are are very good in this sense.
This is of course a problem dependent
kind of answer. So
um then of course we could do argue
which problems are
um lead to to to which kind of
performances.
I see. Thank you.
Okay. Um thank you.
Um okay. So my qu next question is
obviously um if you increase the number
of observations or sampling points uh
that will improve the um probably the
accuracy
um of the reconstructions. Um have you
probably you probably have done that um
you know study like empirically or
theoretically. Uh yes. Uh so yes that's
true. Um
um we also have a sort of a target error
associated with also the quality of the
approximation space and this is
basically uh independent of the
observation. So yes and then we have to
somehow take care of uh of both and on
the other end it's also a trade-off
between accuracy and computational
efficiency. So that's always the
uh sort of uh criterion with which we
try to somehow select the number of uh
um observations and the number of um uh
and the size of the approximation space.
Sure. Um have you done any systematical
um study on that?
Not yeah not really I would say. Um
okay.
Okay. But that would be interesting
future direction as well, right? Yeah.
Yeah. Absolutely. And practical. Um
yeah. And in order to be practical, my
next question would be um extension to
2D or 3D problem. Um any difficulty
you envision? So we we have
um numerical tests in in 2D. So it it
works uh comparable to the 1D case. I
think the 1D is very nice for um
presentation purposes because you really
see the sensors um the effect of moving
the sensors in the uh quality of the
reconstructions. So it in 2D we haven't
we have observed similar behavior. We
haven't done any 3D simulations to be
honest. So in principle I don't see any
um great obstacle but u we don't have
tests.
Okay. Uh Carlos
hi. Um so I was thinking in terms of the
of the case of like a static sensors
right so dynamical sensors clearly the
problem is that obviously the the most
of the of the wave let's say is moving
out of the of the region that you're
covering. Um would you have any kind of
way to to like quantify or compare let's
say what is the coverage that you will
need to have with a static static
sensors over your let's say expected
domain uh versus um you know less
dynamic sensors but that move u with a
wave like is there you know like any
kind ofistic about like what would be
the tradeoffs there like
uh so if I understand correctly you mean
um maybe placing a static sensor answers
but in such a way that globally they
cover uh yeah yeah so basically kind of
what what are your let's say aristics in
terms of like how densely placed do
those static sensors need to be um to be
comparable to to the dynamic ones like
let's say for example in the case that
you had if you had uh let's say exactly
the same number of sensors but you
distributed them let's say uh in the
whole range of your expected let's say
final dom domain. Um yeah, what is the
loss of performance let's say of that
versus the same number of sensors more
closely tracking
the okay? Yeah. So the thing is that in
so if you look at the tests what what we
have done is um say here um somehow very
simple situation they are very
concentrated around the initial state
and
then pretty soon uh the support of the
solution is outside basically the u the
range of the of the sensors. So the
thing is that even if we distri if you
distribute them say in this range say
020 where uh the support of the solution
is somehow moving. Uh the thing is that
some of them uh will somehow be well let
me pass the term be switched off at some
point and this is an effect on the
stability because somehow um your your
observation space becomes smaller in the
sense that um not all the sensors are
playing the role and this causes
instability in the reconstruction. Um so
of course this will be probably less
dramatic.
um we haven't we haven't done extensive
simulations uh uh for this kind of
setup. So this definitely another
interesting thing to look at. So the
somehow decay will not be I would guess
not as dramatic as here. Uh but
definitely um you you will observe
instabilities because sensors are are
just some of them will be switched off.
Say you you put some of them here in
zero then those will uh um will give no
information pretty soon and some others
will just give some information at say
time 10 but coming from something that
is already affected by um a
reconstruction that is already affected
by a rather large error.
Yeah. Yeah. you know that that I mind
that will be obviously was I mind that
will be a trade-off in between let's say
the number of sensors that you will need
a statically to kind of like densely
cover the domain versus yeah like using
less sensors that actually can move with
the solution. Yeah. Okay. Yeah. Then you
would need a lot of sensors you mean or
more sensors and then yeah say try to
cover the the whole sort of region. Um
yeah this this we haven't tried but yeah
then of course it's uh
um you still will observe instabilities
because some sooner or later some will
will become ineffective. Um yeah to
which extents the beta will behave uh in
will goes to zero. uh this is would be
interesting to look at
u kind of let's say corlary to that
would you then expect in higher
dimensional cases this will be more of a
problem just because of you know curse
of dimensionality and you know like
needing more sensors to cover let's say
the same space in higher dimensions
would you then let's say expect the
dynamical um the dynamical uh algorithm
to perform better computationally you
know as the as the number of dimensions
goes up or yeah I mean I I would expect
the dynamical approach to you see even
in 1D uh well adding a lot of sensors is
expensive. So um having few of them that
follow the dynamics
um to me seems uh uh the best option and
yeah I do agree that as you go higher in
in the dimension of the um of the space
dimension uh yeah this
this yeah this is a problem and also um
well the other thing that uh might be
problematic is that you need some
information on the dynamics right
beforehand because otherwise How do you
put the sensors at the beginning? While
with this dynamic approach, you you just
need somehow to know the the the model
that is behind, but you don't know you
don't need to know how the solution will
look like at say time 20. Okay. Okay.
Yeah, that makes sense.
Awesome. Okay. I think you have you know
described how the you know dynamic
sensor location is determined. um based
on the stability the beta um if you go
back to slides 12 or 13 uh that would be
awesome. Uh
there it
that to quantify the stability you do
not need to know about your um system
like for example like governing
equations of the shielding equations you
you do not have to know about it you
only need to observe it and you you you
can still quantify that uh stability
constant right yes I agree there's um so
at least in our approach there's a
dependence amount on the problem because
of the approximation space. Um so the
approximation space moves uh according
to uh to the model that is behind. uh so
if we change the shinger equation with a
different equation then the bn will be
different and will also evolve
differently and then also the beta will
be affected by uh by this
uh yeah in order to be more general
probably that dependent if you can get
rid of that dependency and just purely
um you know quantified by you know the
the reconstruction instructions and all
those uh the observations you have
collected that would be even more
generalizable I would say. Yeah. Yeah.
But but that would be hard to do. Um but
there there must be some way around I
hope because I I I really think that
this is pretty good directions to
pursue. Um and I I truly believe that it
has a a lot of applications out there
especially in engineering side where
they do the a lot of um
experiments. Um well okay well we wow
it's 16 after 11 a.m. here uh in Italy.
How what time is it? Um it's uh 16 plus
8 p.m. 8:00 p.m. Oh okay. Well, thank
you so much for the wonderful talk and
the nice u you know Q&A sessions. Thank
you very much. It was very um wonderful.
Um well with that we can end the
um the the seminar. Let me push the stop
button.
Because